aéroport charles de gaulle ce matin le
trafic de roissy a donc doublé
aujourd'hui avec l'installation d'une
grande partie des services d'air france
la compagnie nationale a désormais à
charles de gaulle
les deux tiers de son activité qu'il
s'agisse d'installation de formation du
personnel de fret ou de transport de
passagers pour la période ibm a commencé
aujourd'hui pour nous parce que la
saison d'hiver commencent à produire et
vendre
cela représente à peu près dix à douze
mille passagers par jour traitées à
roissy pour 4500 à 5000 traité rock et
au point de vue du mouvement d'appareil
bien point de vue mouvements d'appareil
suivant les jours de la semaine nous
verrions entre 120 et 140 mouvement
surcroît si je relis nous serons entre
40 et 45 mouvements d'argent
est-ce que les heure limite
d'enregistrement avec cette installation
à roissy seront modifiés via les ordres
limite d'enregistrement sont déjà très
court puisque 7 25 minutes avant l'heure
de départ c'est la règle générale elles
sont maintenues sur eure voici comme sur
orly ce sont exactement les mêmes donc
toujours 25 minutes à nos amis quelle
que soit la destination
quelles que soient les destinations plus
que jamais si vous prenez la compagnie
nationale il est important de bien vous
assurer de l'aéroport d'embarquement
roissy pour les vols long courriers sauf
vers les dom tom l'europe occidentale et
centrale
la méditerranée sauf l'afrique du nord
orly sud pour toutes les autres
destinations
dix mille passagers connus ou inconnus
ont inauguré en ce vendredi de toussaint
les installations d'air france dix mille
passagers et un champion du monde